[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everyone so yeah my name is Bryan
Hughes you can find me everywhere online
at NAB rias Twitter github things like
that yeah I work at Microsoft so today
I'm gonna be talking about anxiety and
queerness and kind of how that manifests
myself and this like little app that I
built to help me with it first up if
that's going to work do it there we go
content warnings I am gonna be talking
of course about mental illness I'm going
to talking about homophobia growing up
queer in the south so it's gonna be an
intense talk but yeah so anxiety brain
all right I am giving up on that thing
so yeah I deal with a lot of anxiety
it's something I've dealt with for a
long time although it took me a while to
realize it for a lot of reasons but is
something where like my anxiety is kind
of middle of the road I would say I
definitely know people who deal who deal
with anxiety that's a lot less than me
but also people deal with it and it's a
lot more than me it's enough that I am
in therapy it's something I have to
manage and it manifests in a lot of
different ways like mental illness for
most people it's always a little bit
different and so for me one of the big
things the way that anxiety manifests is
that I'm really bad about keeping in
touch with people I really good about
being present like in the moment like
you know talking to you and I think I
talked with a bunch of you last night
and like I'm great at that when it comes
time to like reach out over text or DM
email whatever you know just really
working on that relationship I'm bad at
it and it comes from social anxiety
ultimately and a few other things so I
decided that this was an area where tech
can help like the thing about mental
illness is we're constantly managing it
you know it's not something that you
take a pill and it's fixed it's
something that we have to work on and
sometimes we need tools to help us with
it and so I wrote this tool to help me
with this one very specific aspect of my
anxiety so I call a contact scheduler
I'm not particularly good at naming
things so it's pretty functional but it
works it
open source online GPL license you can
check it out so I created this I had a
couple of design goals in mind to make
sure that it worked really well the
first thing that need to be as automated
as possible any time I have to go in and
do a thing that's a chance that I won't
do that thing and I found like I tried
in the past using just like a normal
calendar to add an entry to like hey
reach out to this person never works
largely because I forgot to just add
stuff to it you know there was a human
error element of it so I needed to
remove as much of that as possible and
the next one is that it needs to be
scheduled aware you know if I ever get a
notification saying hey do this thing
and I'm in the middle of like a meeting
that makes my anxiety worse not better
so a needs to be able to figure out like
when is actually a good time to tell me
about it
and then finally it needs to be low
stakes like the thing about anxiety is
it ratchets up pressure and then
whenever something else is pressuring it
gets worse and it gets into a bit of
this cycle so it needs to be really low
stakes so when I designed it it looks
kind of like this there are three tabs
to it there's sort of a Home tab this
contacts having a calendar tab so on the
context tab I add in all the people I
want to keep in touch with using
Futurama characters here because I like
to use them as placeholders and you
notice this is a very simple UI there's
very very little to it and that is
actually by design
this is still kind of beta so it's
missing some features but this page is
complete so in this page which I see is
not on the monitor right now it's you
got a list of names and you add just a
name and half-free clear you want to
reach out to them very simple and that's
by design it does the rest for me and so
then on the home page each week it's
going to create a queue of people for me
to reach out to you know the sort of
interspersed set throughout the week and
it does it using a variety of pieces of
information you know how often I reach
out to someone when I last reached out
to them and a few other heuristics going
into it and so it's time to reach out to
someone it gives me a notification that
looks like this now if you start looking
at this this is actually kind of
different than a typical notification
even that may not be quite obvious the
biggest thing is compared to a calendar
there is no snooze or dismiss by design
so what I learned with a calendar is the
way it interacts with my anxiety and I
think a lot of people's anxiety is we
get a notification especially a calendar
notification and there's this
that we have to do it right then it's
like you must do this thing at this
moment I'm gonna keep bothering you
until you do
and that really spikes anxiety as it
turns out like that is a UI pattern that
is bad for anxiety and now if you have a
meeting you have to get two at a time
that's just the nature of it but I like
reaching out to someone it doesn't
matter if I do it now versus a half hour
from now it's just matters that I reach
out to that person so I changed this so
that there is no snooze and dismiss and
it's kind of an asynchronous UI pattern
this pops up for like 15 seconds and
then goes away on its own
so it's like an auto snooze and that's
intentionally a very short period of
time so that actually can't respond to
it in that period of time the idea is it
pops up it gets the idea in my head like
oh yeah I need to reach out to this
person then goes away and this
eventually I'll get around to it you
know when I have a few minutes but it's
there in my brain already it's kind of
taking up space and I remember to do it
and so whenever I do reach out to them I
actually have to wait for this to pop up
again and then that's when I hit respond
and then it will move on to the next
person sometimes there can be anxiety
around reaching out to a specific person
maybe I have to have a really difficult
conversation with them or it's been a
long time since I reached out to them
and I'm feeling anxious about the fact
that I haven't reached out to them so
sometimes just saying like okay I'm not
gonna do this person right now I'll
reach out to someone else first that can
kind of help to just like ease the
anxiety and feel me it give me a little
more prep to do it again so that's how
that works you know remix in this
notification pattern has helped a lot
and like this is still beta stage like
this is not a particularly good
mechanism actually you know it can be a
lot better but it's already better than
what we have and I don't say this
because like I have some insight it I'm
actually a pretty bad UI UX designer
it's just that I don't think anyone's
ever tried to create a UI that works
with people's anxiety and and a little
bit I've been using this so far it has
made a difference so I think there's
something to it and so I implemented
this using electrons AS type script
because I love type script you know go
figure working for Microsoft
I used SQLite to store all the data in
it that way it's on a file on your
laptop and you have control over that
you know this is ultima mapping
relationships so that is really
important private information and so you
know i don't want to deal with the
privacy issues of going into the cloud
and then finally i'm not there yet but i
will be using the Microsoft graph API to
connect to my calendars in
during our proper times now you might be
thinking to yourself that like wait did
Brian just finish talking about his app
in a you know 35 minute sock in the
first like ten minutes or so yes that is
exactly what I did the reason for that
is mental health doesn't exist in a
vacuum and there's always more to the
story
my mental held you know anxiety isn't
this like thing that exists in a
crystalline form under a glass jar
somewhere it is intertwined with
everything else in my life and so to
understand my anxiety you kind of have
to understand where I came from and that
truth is I am a bisexual polyamorous
atheist who's born and raised in various
parts of Texas in New Mexico not called
Austin and so I was born in Houston
Texas in 1982 now that actually means
that I'm older than I look I'm older
than you probably think I am I am
technically a gen Xer according to
pretty much every definition and that
actually matters as it turns out so the
born in Houston lived there for three
years moved to a place in Texas or in
New Mexico sorry called Truth or
Consequences that one little star kind
of a New Mexico side and I lived there
for like four years so then I moved to
Denton Texas which is in the north part
of the dallas-fort Worth Metroplex and I
spent all of my adolescence there all
the way through high school and then I
went to college in Lubbock Texas now
taxes in general is a strange place
suffice to say and Denton is a strange
place inside of a strange state as is
Lubbock so Texas the thing is known for
well one of the things that's known for
is that there's a university there
called the University of North Texas
turns out they have the number two jazz
program in the nation you know now
actually my family did that's why I
removed my dad wanted to go back to
school but outside of Texas it's on the
very northern part of the metric so it's
surrounded by farmland and this town was
basically had this very tiny artistic
core and then a bunch of that was
liberal and a lot of really conservative
folks right around it we're kind of all
mixed together then Lubbock though was
sort of the opposite of that Lubbock
when I lived there was rated as the
second most conservative city in the
nation with a population over like a
hundred thousand I think so that is more
what you would expect so I'm giving you
this idea in your head like I grew up in
Texas career person from there you might
have to be thinking you know what that's
like but you're probably wrong actually
yes these places are incredibly
conservative but it doesn't manifest the
way most liberal folks think and this is
a struggle that I have trying to
describe it all the time so most people
think that like homophobia racism things
like that in the south
looks like KKK members burning crosses
or the Westboro Baptist Church picketing
funerals with signs saying that people
like me are going to hell that exists
but it's a very very tiny proportion
like there's only 5,000 KKK members in
the entire United States and that's a
super tiny fraction of the south because
the thing is most big between the south
doesn't look like overt violence it's a
lot more subtle and a lot more pervasive
like the south is I think more racist
and homophobic and everything else and
you think it is but not in the way you
think it is at all and unfortunately
like the thing that I see about this all
the time is there's this strong man
construction created of the south
and what I always see especially white
liberal folks doing with this is they
say like this is what bigotry looks like
this is what racism looks like so I'm
not racist because I'm nothing like this
thing I just made up and that's actually
how this conversation goes down so I've
also lived in San Island San Francisco
now and I lived there for almost a
decade so I know San Francisco as well
and the truth is San Francisco is racist
as [ __ ] seriously look at the history of
it or look at the current numbers on it
San Francisco the population of San
Francisco is only 3% african-american
that is the lowest of any major city in
the entire United States by far like San
Francisco managed to somehow beat up
Phoenix Arizona for having fewer
african-american folks
Arizona
and and this is not an accident either
if you look at the history of it San
Francisco actively chased out
african-americans and we see this going
on today
and the thing is is that like bigotry in
the South doesn't look that different
than bigotry in the West Coast and for
me what that meant growing up though is
like so Texas is a weird thing it's not
quite the south it's like the south
sibling a younger sibling in a way and
it gets a lot of its culture from the
south later also get some culture from
the Midwest and so what this means in
culture especially when I was growing up
is that you just didn't talk about
anything controversial that was like a
major social faux pas it was out of turn
you just didn't do it
the thing is that when I was growing up
queerness was controversial so you
didn't talk about it ever and like this
is it's especially complicated for me
because I'm bisexual I'm not gay and
there is a bit of a difference and
growing up I knew that I was interested
in women dot dot dot but like yeah
growing up especially when I was young
like I grew up with that Internet the
internet didn't come around until I was
in middle school and even back then it
was not like we had today there wasn't a
way for me to find community online
there wasn't a way for me to research
even what Karina's was like that just
didn't exist and there wasn't
representation in media either like Will
& Grace when come on until I was in high
school career I for the straight guy
it's original main one come on till I
was in college like I had no role models
in media I didn't even know what
bisexuality was until like my junior in
high school and I am bi like I didn't
know what I was and and it's not like
people not talking about this was like
oh it's just not a big deal we're not
gonna talk about no this was the
elephant in the room that everyone knew
was there and you could feel it like I
could feel the presence of it growing up
but I didn't know what it was I just
knew there was something and I knew that
something involved me and not just
because how I felt but because of how
others felt like I knew I was somehow
other
going up and not just in that like
teenage angsty no one understands me way
like we all go through that that's not
what I'm talking about this is something
where I knew others were treating me
like and like that sunk in I think about
growing up queer is like I mean
everyone's story is different and it
depends a lot on the culture we grow
around up and but pretty much all of us
deal with homophobia growing up and we
internalize it because when we're young
when we're kids before we hit puberty
very very few of us actually know that
we're queer
like that's something that usually we
have to get to puberty to find out not
always but usually and so what happens
growing up when we grow up in these
environments we grow up in a place where
homophobia is the norm and we learned
that first we learn that there's
something wrong with being queer and
later we find out that we are queer and
we can't just turn that switch off so we
internalize it that's what we mean when
we say internalized homophobia or
internalized racism or anything else is
that we learn what the culture wants
before we learn what we are and then we
have to reconcile that somehow in a lot
of places where homophobia looks like
violence which is a lot of places that
gets internalized as hatred and
self-loathing but like that wasn't
exactly what I dealt with growing up and
for a long time I actually thought that
I just somehow like dodged a bullet with
this that somehow I was like a lucky one
because I don't have that kind of
internalized homophobia but it is there
and this is something I've learned
recently is that for me internalized
homophobia doesn't look like violence
and hate it looks like self-denial and
gaslighting because that's what happened
when I was a kid the oppression of
knowledge was so thorough that I didn't
even know there was something for me to
find out about myself I knew there was
something but I didn't know what and I
didn't have the tools to find it out and
no one to show me the way so that part
of me just got cut off and put in a box
because I knew what's attracted women I
did kind of figure out eventually that
like being gay was a thing once again I
knew I wasn't gay and at the time that
was the only thing that got in about
queerness at all at least some men and
so I knew I wasn't gay but I knew there
was something else
so I just thought maybe I was broken
like there was a crossed wire or
something in my brain and like that got
internalized that just oh there's this
weird thing going on but like the
culture we don't talk about it so I'm
just gonna shove it aside and not think
about it and I did that to myself like
this is by erasure pure and simple and I
erase myself and I'm not the only one
this is a very common story among by
folks very common and so I knew I had to
get out of Texas though especially once
again to college I kind of started
figuring some of this out like I didn't
know this in high school I mean I knew
there was something I knew yeah I knew
the way other people treated me I knew
when Matthew Shepard was tortured and
murdered for being gay that that struck
a chord me that I didn't understand but
I knew I was afraid like that was high
school for me and then college wasn't
much better I started figuring this out
just because I'm getting older but now
is in a much much more conservative
place the kind of place where it's not
just everyone is Christian that's just
the way it is in Texas but this place it
was like at least half of the city was
young earth creationist evangelical
style of Christianity and so like living
in that even more press and I just I had
to cut that side off for me in order to
keep myself safe and I know now that
what I did was I put myself in the
closet without even knowing that closet
was there and I stayed in it for decades
I'm in my late 30s now getting there and
so I'm starting to really work on this
and like I said I've been at San
Francisco for a decade and so you might
think okay I moved to San Francisco
which is a you know a great place for
queer folks it really is and you would
think that that would just fix it but it
didn't it's not just about escape
getting physically away from where
you're out but you have to get away from
it mentally too and I'm still stuck
there in a lot of ways and of course see
like I said San Francisco is not perfect
far from it like what I have learned you
know I do have a lot of street friends
historically the majority of my friends
have been straight and in San Francisco
I learned that you know it's a very
accepting welcoming place for queer
folks but
as long as you stay in line you know
there's certain ways that will they
expect us to express our queerness but
as soon as we start calling out [ __ ]
on the part of our straight friends
there in San Francisco all of a sudden
then we become the device the divisive
ones
we're the ones causing trouble why don't
we just all get along and this isn't
just queer folks this happens to you by
the way this is people of colors the
disabled this is the same story being
told over and over again even in liberal
areas and even in activist circles like
so I'm something of an activist if you
follow me online you might have seen
some of the things I've done I was
involved in the node.js project for a
long time trying to change things there
and I've done a few other things more
recently and activism is a it's a weird
weird thing it's like we tend to think
of activism I was like oh I'm gonna go
protest as family go hold a sign and
chant and that is a part of it that's an
important part of activism but it's just
one piece a lot of the other work we
have to do is more diplomacy and
politics and like that's what I did
that's the style I did and what I didn't
know going in those when you do that
you're not calling out someone on the
other side of a line who you don't know
they're faceless and nameless you're
calling out your colleagues you're
calling out your friends and that in
some ways made my night in some ways it
absolutely made my anxiety worse you
know my anxiety comes from growing up it
comes from not being able to trust
people
it comes from keeping people at a
distance because that's how I stay safe
and I still struggle to trust people I
still struggle to open up a lot like I'm
an incredibly difficult person to get to
know I really am and it's not a great
thing for me I know that in activism in
some ways has made this worse because I
had to work with colleagues and friends
people that were causing problems saying
hey you're being an [ __ ] but also
people who I saw being hurt and one of
the hardest things I've ever had to do
was in the know project I remember this
vividly having to tell people I care a
lot about who were being hurt that I
can't do anything for you right now
because if I do it'll make things worse
and we're gonna lose whatever chance we
had and I think that made that even
harder was a few months later when I
thought we had our chance tried it and
we failed anyways it only proved me
right to tell these people that I can't
help you in that it's [ __ ] hard still
and it just it draw it has pulled me
away from people even more and so yeah
I'm anxious all the time because I have
to deal with this kind of [ __ ] it never
stops
like most of the time it's just a low
hum in the background you know something
I just kind of keeps me on edge keeps me
hanging perhaps a bit too much from a
perfectionist but you know it still
works well or it works I can deal with
it easily enough it's not a big deal
most of the time then there's those
other times where my anxiety gets bad
enough that I can't work like I can't
really maintain relationships
thank God I can work from home which by
the way pro tip for anyone who has
control over this if you want to help
people with mental health allow them to
work from home because if you could be
on the fly on the wall on my really
really bad anxieties you see me pacing
my apartment I cannot sit still I cannot
focus and being at home does help though
because of it at least it's in a calm
comfortable place but it's always there
even when it's not that and thankfully
that's rare just you know half a dozen
times a year maybe a dozen times a year
like it's not that common at least
doesn't feel that way to me but it
happens the reverse is even rarer though
on occasion my anxiety actually will
completely go away it's usually fleeting
just for a few minutes but I really love
those moments because like for this
brief moment I can see the kind of
person I would be otherwise I could see
who I would be without anxiety and I'm a
much that that version of me is a much
better person I wish I could be that
person all the time but I can't I was
never given that choice growing up my
defense mechanisms were honed to a fine
point I had to like and this is the
truth that a lot of queer people grow up
especially when we grow up alone without
support as it hardens us
we don't have a choice in this either
and we don't know how to do it in ways
that are healthy either because we have
to learn it on our own we don't have
people who actually understand this we
don't have therapists to talk to
especially in conservative places today
and a lot of Kurt's Irvington places
therapists still treat weirdness as a
mental illness and for a long time it
was officially classified as a mental
illness but that just makes things worse
it's not true obviously and it's harmful
it's hurtful and so like I'm just I'm
left dealing with this in a lot of ways
it feels like it feels like a part of my
life was stolen from me honestly like I
am Who I am because of things outside my
control that I never had control over
and the fact that it was so subtle
growing up it was never explicitly
mentioned I didn't know there's always
this thing conservatives like to say
queer people oh you're just confused
well you know what your goddamn [ __ ]
right I was confused because you made me
confused you never allowed me to gain
clarity and that is harmful like being
stuck in a closet you don't even know is
there but you know the feeling of it you
know that shame coming in from it that
lasts that sticks and like I think I'm
gonna be this way the rest of my life I
really do I'm getting better like I said
I've been in therapy and that it does
make a difference it really does help if
you are struggling get into therapy
please it really does help I know it's
scary I was terrified whenever I first
got in but it really does help and make
a difference we got to remember this and
we got to remember this in our cultures
and our companies that there are a lot
of people struggling with mental illness
and that comes from a lot of places
that's always intertwined with something
else like for me whenever my anxiety
spikes it's not like a random thing
that's unpredictable there's always
something that spikes it I mean a lot of
times it actually comes back to
queerness in some way or fashion not
always its creative sir activism at the
very least I should say
and it's hard and it's especially hard
knowing that this isn't something that's
just in the past and done with like this
is still going on I remember I had met
this one guy I'm at a conference and a
much more conservative place a while ago
and he was from there he had just moved
to San Francisco like a couple months
prior to the Castro he talked about how
excited he was to be there and how
awesome it was and I saw myself in him
like I knew exactly where he's coming
from and what he was thinking
and when he said that he was excited to
be there what he really meant was that
he finally felt safe and free to be
himself but I know it's not quite that
simple I know you can't just flick a
switch on that and it's all better
I probably and I had the responsibility
to tell him all of this I think but I
just couldn't do it I just couldn't I
couldn't bring myself to tell him that
like you're not out of the woods that
San Francisco isn't perfect that this is
going to haunt you I just I I couldn't
do that to him at that moment but it
sticks with me
and I don't have an ending for the sock
by the way and not because I didn't get
around to it like I do a lot of public
speaking I know how to formulate a talk
I know how to do a plot structure I know
how to bring it in I don't have a talk
for this the I don't have an ending for
this talk because I don't have an ending
to my story a lot of times when I do
culture talks I ended with a call to
action I'm like you know if you could
all do one thing do this one thing it'll
make things better there's no call to
action for this like the damage has been
done I'm gonna be dealing with this for
the rest of my life and queer people
today even younger than me are still
gonna be dealing with this for the rest
of our lives there is no amount of
apology there was no amount of
reparations that can undo the damage
done in the past and this is not just
for queer folks this is for people of
color this is for disabled folks for
anyone else on the outside of society
there is no call to action for this we
have to do better but it can never be
fixed especially while the damage is
still being done today but one thing I
will say though is to anyone in the room
who is queer or listening online for the
recording of this especially if you're
still in the closet find your community
you don't have to do it alone don't stay
in the closet alone like I did because
that is the loneliest place in the world
find your community find that support so
that hopefully it can blunt the damage
but you know it's already done for me so
I just have to keep dealing going
forward and you know building tiny
little JavaScript apps tell me with the
details thank you
you